sugar oh you better put that nasty ass
tongue back in your mouth for rip it out
yes ma'am what you ain't got to protect
me from CET come on C come on Miss
Hill the water it's nothing new for male
comedians to wear dresses and portray
women on screen for livs you just saw
Eddie Murphy Martin Lawrence and Robin
Williams in some of the iconic movie
roles is this part of the recipe to of
success or a cheap humiliation tactic
comedian CAD Williams brought the debate
to the Forefront during a one-on-one
with Sharon sharp Shannon
sharp yo he did not just put him in a
dress he said Sharon sharp that was a
crazy slip that was a crazy slip
yeah yeah Sharon sharp you could she had
a great NFL
career that is wild but he was really
good with the heels I mean the I mean
the
clits Martin tried to put me in my first
dress when he had to go on his Hiatus he
tell me cat when I come back I need you
you my young partner you're my brother
in comedy when I come back just promise
me that my next movie it'll be me and
you we going to do it together we going
to do some buddy cop [__] I said Martin
you got my mothering word my go do what
you got to do when you come back I'm in
your movie don't trip I don't need to
see the script or nothing you know we
get in that office and this fool pull
out Big Mama's House
too I almost died and I got to read this
script in front of all these good white
people where this [__] want me to get
in a dress with him and I'm literally
saying everybody why is he in a dress
again you already played the old lady as
FBI agent we can play anything now we
can be playing a dog catcher this time
why do we need to be in the dress and I
get so mad I say you don't want me you
want Brandon T Jackson and that's who
they went and got twice I said it they
went and got him just like I'm telling
you I had that other dude's work I had
all of it that's how I got in this
position Lord I sure hope I have he's
drinking that CAC like he's sipping tea
I love
it conac is the new tea of
2024 Kevin just shook it off and said
that although it never happened to him
he never mess with something that could
mess up his whole brand uh definitely
have ran into to put on the dress I mean
you know you you have to have you have
to have boundaries you have to have
limits that you refuse to cross at the
end of the day you got to know that
you're a brand I'm a brand uh you need
to protect your brand at all times but
get this a few years down the line Kevin
popped up in an SNL sketch in a dress
and almost immediately his whole career
skyrocketed so you know some of us make
choices I think think it's not a biggest
Choice um for others I'm saying um at
the end of the day Kevin doesn't have to
worry about what people are going to say
about him wearing a dress because of the
long line of dress wearing people before
him so now we had Big Mama's House one
two and three I've never seen media in a
pants suit I think she wears dresses so
now I'm saying why are we picking on
poor little Kevin Hart because it was
his turn next okay some of us are
against the Illuminati and we are
against the Illuminati at our own
detriment when people are against the
Illuminati then they get punched in the
face all the time the Press hates them
nobody likes them now this was a Hot
Topic I remember like 10 20 years ago
like this was a thing that a lot of
comics were talking about yeah um when I
see that they put every black man and
the movies in the dress at some point in
their career i' be connecting that down
like why all these brothers got wear
dress
both of us who watched the Jamie Fox
show loved the Jamie Fox
show that is facts I used to watch that
when I was living in Ethiopia okay love
the dam fox
show the whole cast was
amazing it was on reruns y different
than the fact that Martin and Jamie are
really going to do Shen aanda as a
movie Cat Williams was trying to always
say brand Brandon don't wear a dress you
see because once you do Chen and Wanda
as a movie and we already have big
mama's house and we know Brandon T
Jackson that [__] showed up with his
dress oh yeah yeah he was say in the
media so I thought he was heckling me he
was ready to be in one and
two he was really trying to help me at
the time I didn't know that I was
immature right I feel like dang why I'm
trying to trying to make it you just
start wondering how many [__] really
need to wear a dress
why you bashing me and then he was
trying to warn me you know don't get in
the
dress I'll say this all the celebrities
getting mad at cat right now all these
guys all the top people having something
to say about him I think it's crazy that
all these people got something to say
but they kept their mouth shut when it
was Harvey Weinstein they kept their
mouth shut when it was P Diddy ain't it
crazy you got people actually doing
physical harm pushing themselves on
people none of these [__] have
nothing to say but then when it's cat
who has no power over them all of a
sudden now they outspoken that's why I
wouldn't take much Credence to what most
of these group Falls have to say cuz
most of these celebrities are just for
the cash they can talk about they for
the people they for the security they
want to protect their own blah blah blah
but y'all let PD run through a bunch of
your homies that's a and you clapped and
you showed him love and you linked on
his Instagram that's a good okay all
these [__] do they all know
that's a good point they all know so
don't take none of these people
seriously when they got so much to say
about cat I'm not saying cat is Jesus
I'm not saying cat walks on water okay
I'm not saying cat hasn't lied or
whatever it is or don't have his fault
on whatever it doesn't mean that he's
not saying the truth right now about a
lot of this stuff mhm so all these
people who have so much to say I'm like
where were y'all when all this other
[__] was happening it's crazy how quiet
y'all were because you were protecting
your career but all of a sudden now you
might have the Integrity to come out and
speak about things when it's cat don't
have power over you so you you say [__]
listen a person's character is tested
when they have something to lose and
y'all notice when they got something to
lose when it came to PDD all these
rappers who all about the street life
and all this other [__] they keep their
[__] mouth shut MH but now that it's
cat they want to say something listen
and why is it so
[Applause]
important and they tell you [__] like
but it's funny is
it they come in and it is crazy Hey
listen Ed put in the pictures it is
insane how many guys during that era put
on a dress now I'm not a conspiracy
brain person I don't even think it's a
conspiracy like that people might that's
I just think Hollywood's lazy the same
way they won't put out [__] stop
putting out nerd superhero movies cuz
they make money they just put [__] in
dresses cuz they thought that's how guys
black guys were always going to be
successful they always typ casted black
people and minorities in general Asians
were always relegated to this Latinos
were gang members and gang bangers
pretty much every time and then black
people were often put in dresses and it
changed over time but I just think that
was the mindset back then and I'm this
is sound weird I'm not against
crossdressing I actually think like
especially in the world of theater and
stuff like that it has place okay but
when it's compelled so you can fit some
kind of stereotype when it's like a type
casting thing I have I'm against all
type casting okay I'm against all type
casting and also I also come from a
culture where men wear what people call
dresses okay we have these long
robes you would qualify a as a dress if
a woman wee it men wear it but that's
different it's cultural it's not
compelled it is something that we all do
and they're not made to be worn as as if
it was a traditional woman's dress right
hold up let see I should have it in here
somewhere okay yeah that's okay well I
mean I don't know how you call it in
Ethiopia all right just so you can see
it goes all the way down incredibly
comfortable okay I'm not going to lie
wearing one of these is it's my favorite
thing especially when it's hot you don't
wear no underwear underneath you feel
the wind on your balls [__] feels
amazing pause
but I do it out of my own wants okay I
would feel incredibly uncomfortable if
they you know pulled up one of them
[__] Forever 21 skirts or whatever
these women be wearing okay and said yo
you need def there's not a chance in
hell I would ever do
that wow it's weird seeing JB fox in a
dress no it was it was it was it was
back in and Living Color it was I I
remember that clearly yeah I'll say this
I know exactly how this dress thing
happens okay this what happens you're
with your agent you're in a
meeting and then some producer comes out
of nowhere it's like listen guys I have
an idea okay stay with me what if we
put you in a dress with lots of makeup
on looking very feminine with your broad
shoulders and make you do a
dance that's how it
happens and then you're like no like
come on I think it'd be really good it's
going to be a hit you didn't see what
Martin did it and they'll start selling
you on this [__]
and then and then the meeting will end
and you have some res reservations you
know you have some issues then your
agent starts nudging you because they
want to make their commission like come
on this is your big break don't you want
to make it in Hollywood huh don't you
want to make it on the big screen
there's other movies lined up do you
know who that guy is and who he's
connected to if you reject him you're
going to cost the studio so much money
and you're going to pass on this chance
and someone else is going to take your
sh that's whenever you have a sleazy
[__] agent most
AG my my agent is my me my my manager is
my best friend and [__] like that weird
thing that I didn't want to be part of
happen cuz you have to understand one
thing is that we do this YouTube thing
and it's one thing but you have to
understand that I have a whole last
career here where we at right now okay
so I got movie gigs and stuff I got TV
gigs and I got commercial gigs and stuff
like that and shitty [__] has happened
in the past and stuff that I don't want
to be part of has happened proposition
and and the minute I saying no it's a no
I've never been put in a position but I
know exactly what you're talking about
because I've seen it firsthand I've seen
it from other people I'm like G that
could oh no being pushed on being what
you're talking about is very real I'm
very very grateful and very lucky to
have the people that I have around me
but what you're saying is exactly how it
works and the studios and the people are
going to talk to to you like that and
sometimes if they know your agent is
going to back you up all the time like
my agent and my manager back me up they
going to not want to speak to your
agent they're going to want to speak to
you directly they're going to bypass
your agent right talk and sorry about
the no pun intended go by the back door
yeah that's what they going to try to do
and that's that's 100% true the rer
comes in I think he's the writer he's
like Dave listen we got this hilarious
scene where Martin's sneaking out of
jail so he disguises you as a
prostitute he put this dress isn't that
literally what I described
y yeah yo these producers are the
corniest [__] you've ever seen
I don't even know how they have jobs bro
talentless hacks and they come at you
like it's a good idea and you as a
talent are sitting there like [__] are
you high yo what the did you smoke
that's what you thinking you're not
gonna say because you don't want to lose
that job but in your head are you high
will you find a professional way to say
no but in your head you're like I I
can't believe this is real many of you
already know her she's a 68-year-old
pistol packing Grandma who is quickly
becoming box office go you know her from
last year's Smash Hit Diary of a Mad
Black Woman but he is a Dr Queen
Chappelle was decapitated in front of us
and until we deal with that until we
deal with um the fact that The Devout
Muslim who doesn't eat bacon was accused
of being a crackhead and huh until we
until we establish the fact that they
said that he went to Africa to smoke
cocaine huh when we know they don't have
running water and food over there when
they don't have uh been while depending
where you go but okay when they don't
have paved roads over there okay that's
not true either they have paid Road some
places some places they don't oh cat you
listen what you doing right now hey yo
me and my fellow Africans are being it's
true some place chill out bro you lying
he he doesn't he he doesn't walk on
water he doesn't walk on water guys in
South Africa they have running water in
a lot of places okay sure guys not stay
South Africa mean you go you go to
Nigeria Sy you go to a bunch of places
it depends where you go but I get what
you trying yeah why would you escape
you're going to escape to Africa to do
cocaine and crap yeah this is ridiculous
they don't got the good stuff over there
all the good stuff is here you talking
about somebody who has a wife wife and
children five children and lives on a
farm that's that is true the way that
they treated Dave Chappelle long I don't
remember when he said he didn't want to
do the deal with Comedy Central wor 50
million they said he lost his mind
because he refused the money because he
didn't want to do a role that made him
uncomfortable and they shamed this man
like crazy I'm not going to keep playing
the video um but I just want to talk
about this topic just a bit and this was
Hollywood at the time Hollywood came out
with a meta and once the meta was
established they just try to put every
every black person into it right so like
once the duo of black and white guy
happened then they had the Asian and the
black guy the really funny guy and the
really serious guy and they always want
to rep and once the black man in the
dress took off they're like yo how more
right and then a lot of people took it
like this super emasculating not
realizing they just saw it as a money
Trend now some people want to believe
it's more nefarious or whatever it is I
just think it's mad corny and tacky and
all the black people who jumped on it
just so they could have a chance super
corny too
there's a lot of
things what's the corniest job you've
been
offered oh it's when I was a dancer
dancing in bars is the worst [__] ever
uhhuh why that's dancing [__] leopard
Prince okay I I'll tell you what it was
for me yeah like I'm saying the
Hollywood thing I always found that it
was really very weird the the the
Hollywood I don't know there's something
I find very of and weird about that the
way that you want to portray it
especially in big Medias and to a lot of
people and stuff like that to all the
people out there I don't mind if it's
like in a it's weird I don't mind if
it's in the theater setting or whatever
maybe because this it's the distribution
is less it doesn't care the distribution
is less and it looks very less
Insidious it's in in the Hollywood
sphere it's really weird it's more the
way Hollywood is made it's more than
just haha it's funny there a message
there's often a message or like a where
they want to try to go with with this
like I look at things like for example
every people that every people that have
been winning every black people that
been winning Oscars and stuff like that
it's always been in a role when we talk
about pain it's always it's always when
we see black pain that you win an Oscar
and stuff like that so it's like I don't
want to go and engage into that it's
it's been a discussion that's been going
on for years the Hollywood thing putting
me in a dress I wouldn't do that and I
think it's weird and I understand why
people kind of frown about it and kind
of weirded out about it there's
something
about and it came it came from the way
black people feel about that off often
time comes from slavery slavery yeah I'm
going to say that I'm talking about
people here like all the Americans
talking about that there's a lot of
baggage that comes from that where they
will try to do buck breaking which is
what they they call it back then
emasculating and men that was like just
standing against Authority and stuff
like that they would break them and
that's it's kind of a way of breaking
them people make that that that that
link with Hollywood sure with the people
that are in power and the people that
are trying to make it and trying to they
they try to make that link so for
because of those reason yeah I kind of I
I have to see I am biased about that and
I feel uneasy about that because of
those reasons and I think if you ask
most of them be it Jami fox or Mart
Lawrence and you really sat down with
them and they were giving you heart to
heart I think they regret doing those
roles too Wesley Snipes Wesley Snipes
did it too he
was right no n I don't want to know yes
you yes you and you need to because I
need to stop him and Ru him and Patrick
S was in a whole ass movie in a dress it
was uh two w Fu what was it making their
Community look bad need to stop what is
up with black people getting on these
platforms and feel the need to air out a
dirty laundry bro
all this to say those are my thoughts W
Le if you go put on a dress as a dude
just make sure there's a good reason
okay don't do it for some change s or
some strange anything
else all right that's it for today's two
w food tanks for everything two w food a
editor put two w f there blah blah
Snipes stop your tax evasion we still
love you h